it's not black white it's male female
I think that's the issue that we're
running into no it is black and white
it's very black and white I think that
the interrupting and the aggression and
the implication that someone needs to
back up when I have not taken any closer
steps towards you I don't care but if I
feel uncomfortable it's not and we've
been able to have productive
conversations with black men across the
board and by the way most women but
there does seem to be a divide in
interrupting
and being abrasive and certainly being
more aggressive that's what you think of
black women
whenever a woman or a black woman
aggressive
asserts herself or says this is correct
it's so tired to do that it's so tired
the conversation's now over have a
wonderful day because the way you're
treating me